as
all right welcome everybody we have
something truly special today not just
my man bun which of course I am wearing
as promised but we are potentially going
to see something just 42 minutes from
now as the crew arm crew access arm
retract s' we are potentially going to
see the first US crude missile a crewed
mission rather from SpaceX in their
eighteen years of existence the first
launch from US soil into space since
2011 and we are not going to allow
Donald Trump to take this over and
propagandize as he plans to do already
flying down to Cape Canaveral in Florida
we are not going to let him do it the
man-bun will not let Donald Trump do it
and in fact Donald Trump planning to
speak at 6:00 as if he has anything to
do with the forefront of human
creativity the forefront of innovation
the forefront of all of the things that
this launch will represent if indeed it
happens weather permitting they are all
the opposite values of what Donald Trump
stands for and we will not allow Donald
Trump to take over this very very
special day so we will cover what
hopefully will be a launch we will
hopefully see the spacex missile just
nine and a half minutes after the launch
is my understanding come back down and
land on planet earth something that
before SpaceX was not happening
it could be just an amazing day so I'm
so glad to see all of you here this is
not a drill I am wearing a man bun I
promised two streams ago if we got to 25
members I would do it yesterday I was
lacking an element for putting up a man
bun I have it today and we are here my
friends we are here and just under 42
minutes away from this launch an
historic day an historic day and I'm not
even talking about the launch I'm
talking only about
my hair so welcome everybody Douglas
Hurley and robert Behnken are the two
astronauts who on the Dragon spacecraft
which is a spacecraft there as you can
see at the tip top of the rocket that is
not a new spacecraft a scheduled for 43
for 33 p.m. Eastern time for launch just
41 minutes from now delivering the
dragon to the space station with
astronauts happening for the first time
via a SpaceX rocket a partnership
between NASA and SpaceX it is hair
history today and it is space travel
history all happening at once absolutely
incredible
a few super chats coming in coming in
zest the African asks whether Jimmy Dore
or Richard Pryor is the better comedian
I've only ever seen Richard Pryor's
comedy so I have to say Richard Pryor
thanks to Alan Sachs who says is SpaceX
a department within the space force no
SpaceX is a private company at the
forefront of which is Elon Musk of Tesla
Fame as we are just now 40 minutes with
a shot inside the dragon sitting at the
top of the Falcon rocket by SpaceX we
are just 40 minutes the next milestone
so to speak is that at t-minus 37
minutes just three minutes from now the
dragons launch escape system will be
armed now understand that if the worst
were to happen
well not the worst actually but if a bad
situation were to happen where these two
astronauts Douglas Hurley and robert
Behnken Wirtz who need to abort they
would do so ideally into the ocean where
they would be rescued and it is the
Dragons launch escape system which they
arm at t-minus 37 and we'll listen into
that as we approach
Ricky Crawford says are you going to
post a picture of the man bun on
Instagram I may now if people are
interested yesterday on my Instagram I
posted a
Riaan post quarantine picture of myself
I don't even recognize pre quarantine me
pre quarantine is on the left two days
ago is on the right it's like two
different people and you would have seen
that last night if you were following me
on Instagram at David Pakman and why
wouldn't anybody be following me on
Instagram given what it is that we have
going on there but we will see I may
post a man bun picture to Instagram
Maddie I speedy says will we be looking
at this strongly or powerfully yes we
are going to be powerfully and very
strongly watching the launch over the
next very short period of time as the
president likes to say let me say a huge
thank you what a special day to
Alexander Rasen who is new member number
one today join pakman.com and also
although that's it okay no nothing else
just thanks to Alexander Rosen for
joining the party remember that the
Memorial Day coupon code memorial 20
still works on my website for at least
another few hours set to expire let's
now listen in as we are just one minute
one minute from the scheduled escape
system being armed let's see what's
going on here
sending a manual command to Dragon to
initiate a launch escape and Bob and
Doug are also always able to to actuate
the launch escape handle and initiate a
launch escape themselves as well now
that the system is armed all of this is
currently active on the video
wow it sounds like there's a lot that
goes into it and we did have an
in-flight abort test earlier this year
to test this out can you tell us what we
learned from okay so they actually
Justin it seems like they're running a
little bit ahead of schedule which is
great these things usually run behind
they have armed the launch escape system
the next milestone at t-minus 35 minutes
the rocket grade kerosene also known as
our p1 will start to be loaded and the
first stage liquid oxygen loading will
begin so liquid oxygen and rocket grade
kerosene will start to be loaded at
t-minus 35 you saw them if you caught
the beginning of the stream not not too
long ago that the crew access arm has
retracted that's the arm that's used by
the two astronauts Douglas her
and robert Behnken to enter the dragon
craft they must pull that away as they
have they have pinched that off so that
now they can hopefully two minutes from
now start the loading of both the rocket
grade kerosene and the liquid oxygen so
exciting this is just the best this is
the best and we are 36 minutes from the
scheduled liftoff the first manned
mission or I believe the gender-neutral
term is a crewed mission to the space
station by SpaceX and the first launch
from US soil in almost ten years since
2011 absolutely incredible stuff so glad
that all of you guys are joining me if
you are just joining don't adjust your
televisions this is not a plumb on the
top of my head that is indeed a man bun
I promised it and it is here I promised
it and it is here and you know I don't
know we'll see what we'll see what
happens next but my prediction is that
if I don't get a haircut this week and I
don't know what it'll take to prevent a
haircut if I don't get a haircut this
week by next week
it could be illegal what is going on
with my hair we will very soon see Alex
Stephenson says with the man bun have
the same frequency as Halley's Comet and
swiping right on the looks thanks for
being a champ with the hair peace and
love yes yes yes yes to all of it I
don't understand it but yes to all of it
Miguel Palacios says you mentioned Trump
cannot override churches being open but
the supremacy clause says federal law
overrides state law no but so Miguel you
need to look at the tenth amendment the
tenth amendment explains that if there
is a conflict so so no so let's back it
up if there is a conflict between state
and federal law federal law overrides
but this is not a question of state or
federal law this is a question of the
10th amendment the tenth amendment says
if the Constitution or Bill of Rights
specifically give a power to the federal
government it rests with the federal
government if the Constitution or Bill
of Rights block States from having a
certain power states don't have that
power if the Constitution and Bill of
Rights say nothing the power rests with
the states
the Bill of Rights and the Constitution
say nothing about determining what
organizations are essential since it
says nothing the power rests with the
states very very important thank you to
all the seals botnet Alec Stevenson says
will the man bun have the same frequency
of course of course
Edwin Alexander says watch the universe
get DP'd by the patriarchy live yes we
are about to see it very very soon and
and extremely powerfully and exciting
let me say thank you to the mushroom man
the mushroom man has just subscribed
with a twitch Prime for eight months
saying you look great David don't let
anyone tell you different very much
appreciate it let's check in and see
what is going on now come off the stand
very nice uh-huh so as you can see
dragon is actually broken up into four
quads and each quad has two of the super
Draco engines for a total of eight of
them and as I mentioned they are by prof
engines they have MMH and nto is their
oxidizer
now most abort systems from past space
vehicles I believe like Soyuz Mercury of
hollow they all had a pointy escape
tower where there was essentially like a
mini rocket engine or series of rocket
engines on top and if they weren't used
those that that escape tower would have
to jettison itself from the vehicle if
it was used it would be used to lift the
vehicle off of the rocket
well dragon is a little bit different in
that it's escape system it's actually
integrated into the vehicle and was it
great for a couple of reasons one one
less thing you have to jettison on a
nominal flight and so they're pretty
dormant just those throttle valves open
unless they're used and hopefully they
never have to be and yet I mean the
other thing that that offers you is the
ability to escape from the pad all the
way to orbit because if you jettisoned
your escape system prior to that you
couldn't um so yeah that's that's a
little driving that important is that
Aero much safer design yeah absolutely
thanks for walking us through that
Lauren again the launch escape system is
armed that protects Bob and Doug so that
if something were to go wrong they can
shoot off of the pad away from the
rocket and
parachute to safety and ocean crime that
is such a crucial safety capability and
so now we want to go over to Hawthorne
for an operational update with John this
is what you've been waiting for
thanks Marie we are counting down those
final minutes everything is still
looking good on the Falcon 9 and the
dragon vehicle on time launch but
weather is trending the wrong way right
now we're keeping our ears open in case
we hear that the weather is going to be
no-go for the rest of the count right
now we are counting down at t-minus 32
minutes they don't lock five minutes
right on time the propellants we use on
Falcon 9 are a fuel all right so as we
suspected the weather potentially going
to be a problem today potentially going
to be a problem today we are keeping an
eye on that the countdown continuing the
next milestone now that the propellant
has been loaded both rocket great
kerosene as well as liquid oxygen at
t-minus 16 the second stage liquid
oxygen would be loading understand that
these Rockets have multiple stages which
detach from the dragon vehicle as as the
name stage suggests in stages and the
first stages have been loaded second
stage liquid oxygen would start at t
minus 16 and then at t minus 7 which is
now only 24 minutes away 24 minutes t
minus 7 Falcon 9 would start the engine
chill prior to launch and I'll keep you
posted on other milestones if we go
forward beyond that because again the
weather does seem to be a question mark
at this point in time a welcome if
you're just joining us on Twitter twitch
Facebook and YouTube we are standing lot
by rather for a very very exciting day
we are potentially a half hour from
douglas hurley and robert Behnken
launching on a falcon 9 SpaceX rocket a
sitting inside as you see them on the
right side of the left side of the
screen in the dragon space vehicle this
would be the first launch from US soil
since 2011 this would be the first
crewed launch for SpaceX Elon Musk's
company have
ever ever ever the question now is
whether the weather whether the weather
will hold and we are standing by for
that let me say a huge thank you do Beth
Palmer who is new member number two
today at join pakman.com Jason Wang is
new member number three and in go gala
is new member number four all at join
pakman.com always appreciate the support
and so exciting to be here for something
that we were we are not going to allow
Trump to ruin today Trump flew down to
Cape Canaveral Florida and he plans to
speak in a couple of hours probably
whether or not the launch happens but
I'm not going to be covering it Donald
Trump is the antithesis in every way of
all of the values of innovation and
creativity and curiosity that are
represented by space travel and we're
I'm just not going to allow Trump to to
be a part of this so we're not going to
do that okay let's see Lulla seals
botnet says will you ever apologize for
Bolivia
what did Bolivia do that I would have to
apologize for I don't even understand
the question I've never even been to
Bolivia waffles jirafa says our
four-year-old built an international
space station with two sponges and a
Sharpie love it
Stewart Keating says you should complete
the look by growing a beard I thought I
did this is as much of a beard as I can
grow wear some glasses and wear sleeve
tattoos and finally you should work at a
Starbucks and done yeah Seth Barham says
David would you donate to a Kickstarter
funding a reality TV show that launches
flat-earthers into space and films their
reactions maybe that's an interesting
concept
Kyle Joseph says hey David love your
show could you please give a shout-out
to my beautiful fiance Holly Hakim she's
a huge fan and loves you oh absolutely
huge shout out to Holly I hope being
with Kyle is tolerable and
congratulations on everything
Stuart Keating says wouldn't this launch
in fact aliens with kovat 19 well it's
just going to the space station so I
don't think so
wah-wah crit
says flat-earthers are nervous as poop
right now yes they are ver this is a lot
what an incredible TV you know movie set
that they are doing all of this on right
isn't that just absolutely amazing if
you're just joining us we are now at
t-minus 27 minutes and let's get a
little bit of an explanation as to what
we would expect if there is a launch
first and second stages separate and
send dragon on its way to the space
station and once it gets on orbit
mission operators will prepare dragon
for on-orbit operations where dragon
will execute a series of burns that are
gonna gradually raise its orbit to align
more closely with the International
Space Station you're seeing some of that
track in the animation on your screen
right now it's the best gas we're doing
enough for sex for what racket Oh sounds
like we're going at a weather update
real quick really going key moment grant
Baker
yeah we're currently just evaluating one
constraint a constraint on the field no
rule which looks at lightning energy
dissipation we expect to have an update
at about t minus 20 and more information
there and whether I'll be able to
continue into the prop load or or scrub
at that time
okay gang thanks for the update we
appreciate it all right so nobody so you
see some more words in about six minutes
okay so it sounds like we're gonna come
out in about six minutes if we're gonna
have enough time and John I was
referring to a couple of those weather
situations where we have to have a
signal a certain amount of time in this
case with the field mills about 15
minutes so they have until about 16
minutes and 30 seconds oh really make
sure that we're gonna be dealing with
some elements of weather there and that
is at this point it seems if this launch
will be scrubbed it will be because of
weather we should know in the next six
to ten minutes if this launch is
scrubbed the next launch window which
has to do with essentially aligning the
position of the earth relative to the
space station such that the trajectory
is the optimal trajectory the next
launch window is Saturday it is Saturday
so we will see we are still optimistic
about about today okay a thank you over
on twitch to everybody who is joining
and watching I already thanked the
mushroom man who subscribed for eight
months with prime and I welcome anybody
else who is interested in supporting via
twitch of course let's see Kevin why
cough has subscribed on YouTube Bernie
Sanders says I love your show in
perspective but you I thought didn't do
well on Joe Rogan you seemed dismissive
and rude towards Rogen his audience
hated you yeah I just disagree and you
know I can't control likes on the
internet and none of that really matters
and I thought it went fine Daniel
Krieger says if NASA had a real budget
we'd live on Mars now I don't know about
that
hula seals botnet says you supported a
coup no to remove a solid pink tide
leader to have him replaced by a
far-right religious fanatic who promptly
abolished free speech Oh yet no none of
that is true I never supported any coos
and I don't support far-right religious
fanatics certainly none of that is true
Daniel Krieger says you did great on
screw that guy yeah listen I mean Joe
Rogan's audience on average is well to
my right so you know I kind of have two
options I can go on and play like faux
moderate and I can play faux moderate
and then I'll get more likes but what am
i doing I'm not even I'm pretending to
be someone that I'm not or I just go and
I say what I think and a lot of people
don't like it and it has no impact
whatsoever on my life other than I got
internet dislikes and we still got I
think about 6,000 new YouTube
subscribers thanks to the Joe Rogan
appearance which is amazing in a single
day in a single few days so it was a it
was a fantastic appearance in that sense
okay we are now under 24 minutes away
from the scheduled launch NASA and
SpaceX together the SpaceX Falcon 9
rocket scheduled to lift the Dragon
spacecraft to the International Space
Station with two astronauts aboard
Douglas Hurley and Robert bankin if this
does not happen due to weather then we
are looking at a Saturday launch a
Saturday launch and that is where we are
right now let's listen in a little bit
and see what else is being discussed
it's an incredible number I think you
know realizing that you don't have to be
a military astronaut or a NASA astronaut
to fly in space you can be a regular
civilian oh just a regular purse and
going off to space on a spacex type
rocket so I think that's why the numbers
are so high yeah and we are really
thrilled to to see all the folks
watching along online I know we
certainly hope that that this is a go
but we're again we're gonna hear a
little bit of a weather update in less
than three minutes now and Leland you
know I know they're waiting for a
weather update and they've come you know
almost all the way down the count what
do you think Bob and Doug are thinking
about right now
you know we on 120s 129 all right so
just a couple of minutes from that
weather update incoming couple of other
super shots coming in joe romeiro says I
thought your Rogen show was great David
Shaun Conklin's has just discovered you
yes to recently like your style don't
apologize for ruffling feathers keep it
up I'll be watching yeah can you imagine
like on the one hand I say what I think
on the other hand I come up with
[ __ ] to get likes on Joe Rogan right
I mean it's like you know maybe based on
your moral values you would go the other
way
but I just show up and say what I think
and if people don't like it that's it
right I mean that's it what can we what
can we do
Tyler Schneider says I love your show
and beautiful job on Rogan Katie pasillo
says you're doing great thank you for
all that you do
Travis hardware says also rest enjoyed
your Rogan experience appearance hope it
happens again
any chance of appearing on Yang's new
podcast I would be glad to appear with
Andrew yang anytime as you might
remember it was sam harris and me who
first interviewed andrew yang yang back
in 2018 when he started a campaign
focused around the idea of universal
basic income and we've had him on
several times since and i would be glad
to be on his program or have him back on
mine it is a wide open invitation
wide open invitation for andrew yang all
the time thank you so much if you were
just joining us this is a little bit of
a different stream we are this is just
everything is so horrible lately 100 k
deaths with the virus economy imploding
on and on and on we are here for a
historic launch the first crewed space
mission by spacex and the first launch
from US soil since 2011 two astronauts
in the dragon spacecraft which you see
there sitting at the top of the falcon 9
rocket falcon 9 rocket is the type of
rocket that comes back down to earth and
lands we don't just jettison it and
throw it into the trash it actually
comes back and lands it is an amazing
thing
spacex of course is an Elon Musk company
and we hope to get an update let's see
if that update is coming at t-minus 20
scrubbed because because you do have so
much criteria that you have to meet
and we're gonna listen in now we're just
seconds away from a weather update gauge
to rp1 loadcomplete
so they have finished loading the rocket
great kerosene that's the RP one that
they just mentioned in addition to
rocket grade kerosene the Rockets are
loaded with liquid oxygen you see
venting off the rocket that's completely
normal and expected as I was saying
standing by for a weather update so
unless you can give us another admit I
don't think we're gonna get there with
any of the rules today oh no I mean
another 10 minutes bath d0o
6:40 16:45 local I think we probably
clear on all the rules but not quite not
quite gonna make it for this so they're
asking for it okay yeah we got wait
there's someone were starting to
countdown but we still have one above mm
so it Beckett's below not the news we
were hoping for not the news we were
hoping for at all my friends and that
didn't sound great right there that was
the weather net going out but we're
still standing by for a final decision
so it sounds like what they're saying is
scheduled for 14 1633 meaning 4:30 3
p.m. Eastern Time it sounds like they're
saying in order to meet the launch
requirements they would probably need
another 10 minutes to what they
described as six of 16:45 that would be
like an extra 12 minutes 4:45 p.m.
Eastern Time and we will soon get an
update on that ok not what we wanted to
hear and indeed if this doesn't happen
today the next launch window is Saturday
Saturday would be the big the the next
launch window to attempt a few other
folks we're sending you to listen in for
an update but in the meantime we're
gonna go over to Jon instructor at
SpaceX headquarters in California
John okay so we're standing by for an
update there and we will keep an eye
Scooter McGee so sorry let's see I
missed a few shattered the earth says
worked for SpaceX for three and a half
years wishing my former colleagues the
best of luck school
McGee says love your show keep it going
Stuart Keating says any chance of
another Jesse Lee Peterson interview
sure I would do it
Katy presidio says last name Pacino oh
okay good attempt though sorry about
that
the the perfect storm says thanks for
the commentary while Angela Santiago
says hi David a while back you did a
town hall livestream with members
skyping in and asking questions do you
think you might try that format again
maybe we may do that when Matt Chavez
says 2020 t rump still president brink
of World War three Kobe died Australia
and Amazon were on fire global pandemic
toilet paper shortage giant Hornets so
what are a lien z' next incredible t v--
says you're a champion of the left david
balanced informed and unafraid of
calling it how you see it thanks for
covering something like right now light
right now i like oh i see I'm truly
depressed about George Floyd it hurts
yeah I put out a couple tweets about
that it's it's so depressing
Edwin Alexander says spit this failure
to launch is sponsored by blue chew whoa
Raymond prices have you seen the
expansion do you think it's there in the
realm of possibility to colonize Mars
and the asteroid belt in the near
distant future more distant but it's
certainly in the realm of possibility
let's take a listen man copy all we've
heard the call from the crew they have
been informed the launch director mike
Kaler has called a scrub for the day it
has been spraying we got the feedback
when the dragon team and formed a bob
and dog they said we gave it a good try
if they understand and we are here to
try another day so right now we did
officially hold the clock it looks like
a t minus 16 minutes 54 seconds the
launch automatic sequence that controls
the Falcon 9 the loading of propellants
the cycling of valves dad is also
stopped we now proceed into what is a
normal scrub sequence for us we practice
this every launch so now we move into
safely taking the propellants the
pressurization gas is back off the first
and second stages then we will disarm
the and so with that SpaceX launch
director there it is they will now
initiate the scrub procedure a lot a lot
a lot of volatile elements have been
loaded onto the Rockets both are p1 also
known as rocket grade kerosene liquid
oxygen all now have to be unloaded the
clock is gone because the launch has
been scrubbed and the next launch window
I believe it is Saturday let me find the
exact information here where did I have
that I don't remember exactly what time
Saturday one of you may be able Ono here
it is Saturday at 3:22 p.m. Eastern Time
and if that doesn't work they have a
launch window on Sunday May 31st 3:00
p.m. Eastern Time and my goal would be
to cover those because they really will
be incredible incredible days we will
continue to follow the scrub procedures
that will now start remember that you
can always support the streams by
grabbing memberships at join pakman.com
for people have done so and you can do
that now we have a code up there 20 20
now which is a beautiful code but
there's actually a secret code which was
a Memorial Day discount code Memorial 20
to zero all lowercase no spaces and you
can take advantage of that one if you
want and as you know the man bun today
which this is the first day in all of my
days on this on this planet that I have
had a man bun it is brought to you by
membership in fact we reached a
membership goal two streams ago and it
came with a promise that I would indeed
Sport the man mud man bun which I am
sporting right now and that is an
extraordinarily exciting thing that I
can assure you it has never seen before
has it has never been seen before and
may never be seen again it may never be
seen again
let's take a listen now as they initiate
the scrub procedure
I'm rocket so they'll have to wait until
all that fuel comes off they'll disarm
the launch escape system which still
stays armed because they're still
sitting on on a partially loaded rocket
and then once they're able to disarm
that launch escape system the crew arm
will swing back out they'll make their
way once again back the way they came
and then we'll be back to crew quarters
for Bob and Doug for a few more days
what a disappointment but you've got to
do what's safe safety first
imagine if that were a guiding principle
for the current year just now tuning and
wondering why we're not still counting
down we did have a launch scrub today we
were just a little understandable for
it's our humble
hope expecting about a and they will now
start unloading that liquid oxygen
James Montalbano asked this audio only
stream of the bonus show exists anywhere
for members if so where is it video only
yes there is a combination podcast feed
that is the commercial-free full show
audio and the bonus show audio if you
want to get information for that feed
just log in at david pakman.com slash
log in the first page that comes up will
in you can read there and you will get
the information for the audio only audio
only bonus show feed which is part of
the full commercial free member feed let
me say a huge thank you to nathan
corydon who is new member number five
today using the coupon code memorial 20
an exciting coupon code that we've been
looking at very strongly over a recent
period of time i also want to say thanks
to america for subscribing with twitch
prime and brent stone for subscribing
with twitch prime if you are just
joining us the spacex nasa launch has
been scrubbed due to weather they were
scheduled to launch at 4:30 3 p.m.
eastern time with which would have been
just 10 minutes from now because of the
weather they said we they probably
needed an additional 10 minutes and the
decision has been made to scrub the next
launch windows are Saturday and Sunday
both around 3 p.m. Eastern Time and we
will be with you for those presumably
presumably as I like to say a couple of
other things you may or may not have
seen that a video has now been released
of George Floyd before he was killed by
police
clearly was not resisting as is often
mentioned now if he was resisting that
still wouldn't justify killing him with
the need of the head but the the trope
of resisting is clearly not accurate so
you can check that video and link out on
my Twitter page at D Pakman also it's a
curious thing you know we've had all
these protesters including armed
protesters absolutely losing their [ __ ]
on and around and below and on top of
police officers and the police officers
seemed to do very nothing but somehow
George Floyd is dead something of a
conundrum a conundrum something of a
conundrum I posted to my Instagram David
Pakman before and after of the
quarantine and I've got to be honest I
barely even recognized the before like I
feels like I haven't looked like that
for years even though I mean I guess
that was me just a couple months ago but
that's on my Instagram at David Pakman
and over on Twitter Donald Trump
planning to planning to propagandize
around what is now a failed launch with
NASA and SpaceX I will not be carrying
it I'm not going to allow Donald Trump
to take advantage of this politically
Donald Trump has been tweeting literal
loony nonsense like Obama gate makes
Watergate look like small potatoes
Twitter has now shown that everything we
have been saying about them is correct
big action to follow threatening to shut
down Twitter threatening to quote
regulate Twitter by by which he means
censor Twitter really really crazy day
for the president absolute lunacy and no
shortage certainly of things that we
will be discussing on tomorrow's program
believe you me let me say thank you to
Stefan Nair who is new member number six
today at join pakman.com and charles
schöner who is new member number seven
today at join pakman.com the launch has
been scrubbed and so I'm going to take
the opportunity to get started on
tomorrow's program I will be back with
you with that and we will be back
hopefully Saturday hopefully Saturday
with a successful launch of the Dragon
spacecraft
at the tip of on the tip of the making
up the tip I guess of this Falcon 9
rocket sitting at the very top thanks
for joining me
unfortunately no launch today but we
will see you very soon hopefully for a
successful one
you